foreign
college is located on the outskirts of
Washington DC in Maryland
it was founded by General Kinley who
owned the land it was built on
the college is divided into several
sections with the main campus a Subway
connection a small Chapel a library and
a Student Union building
General Kenley was a member of a secret
society called the Golden Architects
whose scripture can be found embedded in
the floor and walls of the College
library along with a large Obelisk
Monument surrounded by the campus
buildings and located in the quad
there is an interesting addition a crypt
found within the church and a statue of
a silver lady outside the library
Henley originally decreed the college to
be founded as an education in line with
the core beliefs of the order and was
established for the men of Maryland
however the impact of World War One
meant that there were dwindling numbers
of men who were interested in
prioritizing their education and instead
we're focusing on starting families
so in 1920 the college opened its doors
to women as well mainly as a way to keep
the money rolling in
there is very little information on the
golden Architects and the college is
very tight-lipped about the society
however located in the library's special
collection is the original student
Charter and code of conduct and found
within its chapters lies some
interesting and questionable sections
which seems to point towards belief in
their own superiority and favorable
seclusion of those who do not meet their
particular standards
student Eva Garcia leaves her mom a
voice message to let her know she's
arrived safely back at Canley College
after she spent Thanksgiving at home
she expresses that she's excited about
the upcoming Derby ball and can't wait
to celebrate with her peers
she also mentions that her roommate is
currently sick however doesn't seem too
concerned and is offered to go to the
pharmacy to pick up her antibiotics
Eva reminds her mum to make sure she
listens to a podcast so either can gain
her extra credit from a professor
flight wasn't garbage we were delayed
three hours and had to switch planes
because some fatty broke the plane
good news blue ladies killed at the
lacrosse Derby Derby ball this year is
going to be sick the team is amazeballs
mom I gotta go my roommate just came
back she's not feeling great they think
she has strep or something I promise to
go to the Health Center and pick up her
prescription
anyway just wanted to let you know I
made it back and didn't get murdered on
the Metro love you
don't forget to listen to my podcast
Prof says I need at least 50 lessons to
get the extra credit
Dr Sandra Benson is the in-house
physician at Kinley college and her
close friend Dr Patricia Thompson who
works at the free clinic in Brooklyn
together they're discussing the spike in
flu cases following the Thanksgiving
break and how the health system has
stretched to nearly full capacity
however this is not surprising as it is
very common for these increases at this
time of year anyway yet Patricia notes
that for some reason the presentation of
these flu cases seems off and that Sarah
is put them on yellow alert
grant money you look at it I don't know
about you but the health center is
basically a capacity
stream this year is really bad you've
definitely had an influx in two cases
but the presentation seems off Sarah's
gut is on a yellow alert that's normal
at this point I'm just handing out hand
sanitizers and condoms hoping they'll be
responsible and I don't run out of
antibiotics
scene last thing I need is another
chlamydia outbreak these kids need to
blow off some steam but the Derby ball
always ends up with at least one kid in
here with bronchitis or a broken leg
because they're trying to impress some
girl
I don't know if I have it in me to deal
with that [ __ ] this year it could be
worse you could be handing out methadone
because the clinic down the street lost
its funding yeah never have to worry
about funding in Academia
just getting the deliveries out to the
boonies you've got a metro stop
the only drugs will deliver on the Metro
I'm not allowed to prescribe
welcome to Kenley cast the only podcast
foreign about Kenley college that gets
you extra credit in your history and
media production courses this is Eve and
today we are talking about the history
of Kenley exciting stuff I know we've
all heard the rumors about the secret
society that constructed the obelisk in
some of the buildings on campus but
what's the truth well our beloved
General Kenley was a member of the
golden Architects he was the original
owner of this land and he did decree
that the college be founded so that an
education in line with the core beliefs
of the order could be established for
Maryland men and the reservoir be built
to serve the moral intellectual and
practical needs of Maryland Like This
Guy's super had a savior complex and I
know it was Normie for his time but
that's toad Sexes now
things are starting together momentum as
the number of flu cases continues to
rise and Sarah is becoming increasingly
more consumed
Dr Benson is dismayed with the inaction
of the college's Administration and
expresses her frustration with a friend
Dr Thompson
they are adamantly refusing to cancel
the Derby Ball even after she is
expressed a deep concern for the growing
number of flu cases that aren't
responding to treatment
both women can see firsthand the
devastating impacts of this new strain
and what they are now beginning to more
strongly believe is not just a simple
case of the flu
just tell me the truth I [ __ ] hate
this rumor no [ __ ] Sarah's talking
about quarantine procedures advising
people to wash their hands and stay home
if they feel sick I've got at least five
cases that aren't responding to
treatment
I'm running out of beds and ask the
president of the college to evacuate one
of the dorms to set up the quarantine
and cancel the Derby ball he tells you
to go [ __ ] yourself called the a fear
Monger accuse me of trying to create a
panic so I get a raise
Academia well it'll come out of its
bonus when they have to pay the wrongful
death lawsuits
as satisfying as the idea of that
chuckle [ __ ] losing his job is I'd
rather not be toe tagging my kids I get
you do you have any casualties first one
yesterday how old four little blonde
girl
mom's an auntie faxer
and miso soup would cure her and she
finally bought her in she'd lost 10
pounds and was severely dehydrated
wasn't anything I could do her heart
couldn't take the stress
laughs
foreign
podcast where extra credit is not only a
bonus but a requirement for listening in
As Time Marches On so does the progress
of time where were we
so yeah Kenley not a bad dude but also
not the greatest I mean he's no Lincoln
and he's no Lee and for an institution
that didn't allow women until 1920 which
actually that's pretty good like that's
six years before Sarah Lawrence was
established so yeah a good on you Kenley
college for being ahead of the curve on
that one please
the reason the real reason they let
women in wasn't because they were super
Progressive or anything it's because
they needed the money World War one had
like totally ravaged the population and
there are not a lot of dudes looking to
get their education when they were
worried about starting families and
those who were were dealing with PTSD
and the influenza pandemic that wiped
out a lot of potential student bodies
however there were a lot of spinsters
looking to make something of themselves
and Kenley capitalized on this new
demand for Higher Learning for ladies in
order to go co-ed two additional dorms
were built to house the new students I
mean it was the Roaring Twenties but it
was still the 20s and like way before
the sexual Revolution was even a thing
and it took like another 37 years for
Kenley to be like no we don't want to be
associated with that creepy ass secret
society BS anymore they wanted to appear
more modern and liberal and tried to
Rebrand the college as a Bastion for
free thinkers and exploration
but there is still some really jacked up
[ __ ] in the student code of conduct if
you haven't seen the original charter
and code of conduct yet you should check
it out in the library special collection
it's creepy as [ __ ] I mean like there's
a section on how Puerto Rican you can be
to be a member like what
Dr Benson's fears have become a reality
and as a result the Derby ball has
become a super spreader event
she confides in Dr Thompson that she's
beginning to believe that the cases are
showing similarities to smallpox
to get some more definitive answers on
what they may be dealing with Dr
Thompson has sent some samples to the
laboratory and requested that they test
specifically for smallpox
15 new cases the Derby ball [ __ ] told
him you let them have a party kids who
are sick as [ __ ] were down a bunch of
painkillers smoke and drink until they
feel good enough to party and then
infect each other we had to lock the
doors and turn people away yesterday
two of my nurses are out and the longer
this [ __ ] goes on the more unconvinced
it's not the flu
I didn't know better I think it was
smallpox but that's [ __ ] crazy
it's not that's what we're all seeing
here that's the room that Sarah keeps
trying to kill because they don't want
to start a panic we have to quarantine
the kids and Evacuate the school we
don't have the resources to deal with an
outbreak like that I gotta get this
[ __ ] to listen to me I send some
samples to the lab told him to test the
smallpox should have them back in a
couple of hours I can email you the
results maybe seeing it on an official
letterhead will make him listen to you
welcome back to kindly cast the only
podcast that's still casting I know
we've talked about some of the weird
[ __ ] on campus like the obelisk I mean
could there be like a morphallic symbol
just hanging out in the quad we get it
you are a men's organization you need
the penis Beacon to light your way it's
super weird but like not as weird as the
fact that there's like a church with a
crypt on campus like
like why is there a crypt who's buried
in the Crypt
is a cryptocrypt without bodies like if
the Crypt doesn't have bodies is it just
a basement and like if we get high Spock
and try to hold Seance in the church
basement is that like super weak sauce
compared to holding one in the Crypt but
it's weird right
and like I've gone to the library and
tried to research the [ __ ] but like a
bunch of the golden architecture that's
just embedded in the floor and walls the
college doesn't really want you to know
about it oh and like the statue that's
in front of the library that like weird
silver lady you know why that's there
right some chick in the 70s got tired of
staring at the big dick in the quad and
so she was like we need a naked chick to
counterbalance that [ __ ] that's some
white feminist nonsense like not to body
shame or whatevs but just throwing a
naked silver lady that blinds the [ __ ]
out of you on sunny days in front of the
library does not offset the huge marble
dong that you can see from space and I
swear to God sometimes if the angle is
right that Obelisk is like right between
her tits and she's grabbing it and like
the mirror reflection titty [ __ ]
thing is like so not what the artist
intended
probably shouldn't smoke and then record
this podcast
good thing this shit's not live
Eva leaves a voicemail for her mom they
let her know that she's coming home
she's frustrated with the school's
closure the hours she wasted on doing a
podcast for extra credit and that her
final exams have been canceled
the dorm is getting converted into a
quarantine is the health center can no
longer accommodate the number of six
students
hey mom so school is [ __ ] closed I
did all those stupid podcasts for no
reason
finals are canceled and they ordered an
emergency evacuation of Campus
last night I got kicked out of the dorm
and moved to another dorm because there
wasn't any more room at the health
center roomie got to stay because they
still don't know what's wrong with her
it's [ __ ] scary there's all these
rumors going around and everyone's
afraid of getting sick and like now I've
got a tickle on my throat and I'm like
is this how it starts like are they
gonna let me get in Chad's car and leave
cat offered to drive me back home it's
kind of nice of him but also like after
that [ __ ] he tried to pull freshman year
I don't know that I want to be in a car
with him for three days you know
anyway just wanted to give you a heads
up that I'm coming home and then I need
pozole love you make me pozole
task force Proteus was a convoy made by
the jtf in order to search areas around
Washington DC as well as Recon they were
also tasked with Scavenging any supplies
they might come across while on patrol
eventually after a number of weeks of
exploring the outskirts of DC they
stumbled upon a cache of valuable
supplies
a number of high value items were
located including a mobile shd server
three military grade servers a
Communications jamming Hub discarded shd
Tech encrypted radio handsets two large
tanks full of chemicals and some
explosives
on their way back to their base of
operations in the capital they happened
upon what they believed to be an
abandoned campus by the name of Kinley
College
a decision was made by the leader of the
Convoy party to proceed into the school
and see if they could find more valuable
resources
unfortunately the campus wasn't
abandoned and not long after entering
the area they were ambushed by a group
of outcasts
the outcasts had made Kinley College the
headquarters and with their large
numbers and the element of surprise on
this side they very quickly overwhelmed
the task force and eliminated the
majority of them
within Proteus there were several jtf
Engineers of which the outcasts took
hostage and with those same supplies
that the Convoy had acquired the
outcasts ordered the engineers to
develop some new weapons
soon after a distress signal was sent
out to the gtf based in Washington DC
along with the division
this is actually one of the many scripts
that I started years ago but had
abandoned in favor of other projects I
was working on at the time
my wife recently dug this one up
stripped her right back rewrote it and
here we are I'm sure this is a bit of a
blast from the past for a lot of you and
myself to be fair apart from Gathering
the footage for this video I don't think
I've been to Kenley college in years
anyway hopefully you enjoyed this in
extremist malice extremely remedial
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]